le grand débat national c'est la réponse
d'emmanuel macron au mouvement des gilet
jaune
j'ai roulé par ce que je vois
au travers de ce qui se passe que les
gens ne croient pas une grande majorité
des gens d'une façon on ne pourra pas
changer cette espèce de l'oligarchie qui
se trouve là haut je crois qu'on est
quand même un nom en france est content
de ce qui se passe actuellement
en fait le pouvoir enfin débattre et
pour enfin plus mais plus facilement
d'opinion pouvoir début de la série en
demi finale et jarret en gironde où la
contestation a été forte
la parole s'est libérée pour mettre des
mots sur les difficultés les
préoccupations du quotidien
je suis en colère vous savez quand on a
une situation de rsa on calcule tout
tout devient un problème au quotidien
donc pour faire la démarche de venir un
départ à se déjuger
on va dire plutôt théorique politique ça
demande un effort il faut avoir
confiance dans la politique il faut
avoir confiance dans ces débats et j'ai
fait cette démarche là est la première
fois je suis venu lui servir à quoi ça
parle même le personnel oui mais je suis
pas là que pour les problèmes des
personnages mettre aussi des mots sur la
crise de nos institutions
entre doutes et attentes au gouvernement
de surpoids nos présences surprendre et
de justement elle fléchit res te dire
que je me suis trompé de cap
je vais le revoir
[Musique]
comme partout en france pendant deux
mois à sadirac deuxième ville de gironde
après bordeaux on a joué le jeu du grand
débat
mesdames et messieurs on va pas tarder à
commencer
et avant que je vous explique tout le
roux rappelle qu'on est à la dernière
séance les grands débats nous allons
travailler sur la démocratie et la
citoyenneté
merci un kit avec des fiches pratiques
et des questionnaires a été mis à
disposition pour organiser des réunions
le maire en marche les a suivis à la
lettre c'est tout naturellement qu'il a
répondu à l'appel du chef de l'état au
vu de mes opinions politiques il est
évident que j'ai vraiment brillé sur
ceux sur cette affaire parce que je
pense qu'il est absolument nécessaire
d'expliquer la politique était derrière
pouvoir avoir des éléments de langage
qui permettent à l'arrivée de faire
évoluer notre pays
à chaque fois des tables rondes pour
favoriser la prise de parole et parmi
les questions qui font réagir celle sur
le rôle du sénat et de comment le faire
évoluer
il faudrait rappeler à nous élus que ce
sont nos représentants et non pas nos
dirigeants c'est surtout parce que
lorsqu'on est coupé des balles à son
assuré luz et là il parle toujours de la
représentation nationale
les jurys qui sont nos représentants
plus et donc il faudrait exiger d
par exemple une fois par mois et
pourquoi elles feront comprendre le
sénat il était venu au suffrage indirect
ne faudrait-il pas qu'il soit plutôt élu
au suffrage direct avec une
représentation différente de citron la
sénatrice françoise cartron en marche
elle aussi a répondu présentes à chaque
fois pour aider à défendre l'exercice je
voyais une feuille pratiquement blanche
et dont je pose la question c'est quand
et on dit mais c'est à dire qu à force
d'échangés
on est parti d'une idée simple et on
voit que finalement c'est très complexe
donc on sait plus comment le traduire
parce que l'idée simpliste bon même
peut-être il faut supprimer le sénat
bon mais après on va plus loin ah oui
mais parcours le remplace que les
lorrains et là on sait plus on dit c'est
difficile dont je crois et mais ça
serait un bel exercice démocratique et
qui fait cheminer quand même je trouve
la pensée
mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
deuxième étape le rapporteur de chaque
groupe fait la synthèse des premiers
échanges en celui-ci de la population
ont des économies pour écouter ce que
chacun passe aussi un par un dans le
monde de la politique
beloeil santé eu on a l'impression
fédéraux car notre tape orientations que
ils sortent se dégage du peuple et c'est
un monde à part
puis vient l'heure du débat entre tous
les participants et le jeu des questions
réponses le sénat on le trouve les
représentants trop lourde et à quoi
sert-il aujourd'hui quand je vois le
président de l assemblée nationale qui
arrive pour une séance
accompagnée par une autre et devient
république un vent nul ne pourrait très
bien il est fait simplement il descend
sa voiture il va prendre son poste
y a pas forcément besoin de 54 et depuis
quand montpellier dans les pures 19e
c'est franchement on préfère se
plaignent un peu plus moderne et ça
n'enlève rien à la tenue les débats
alors le protocole bons à six mois je
vais vous bien vite très fragile c'est
la tarte à la crème is an oui le
protocole n'en sait comment bien comme
partout il ya des huissiers qui sont
tenus oui eh ben moi je dis que la
république aussi c'est bien qu'elle ait
qu'un attribut qui identifie et qui ne
lui donner quelque part de temps en
temps une petite sur la joue théâtre
animé de fiscalité en question
d'habitude 30 euros
il faut expliquer celui qui est piqué et
je trouve que ça c'est hors des
campagnes électorales on n'avait pas
beaucoup de moments comme ça des changes
sans enjeu immédiat et je trouve que là
c'est une bonne chose
[Musique]
qui mieux que les mères ces élus proches
du terrain pour porter l'initiative
c'est ce à quoi emmanuel macron a voulu
croire mais tous n'ont pas adhéré
volontiers
vincent de dieu fait partie de ces
maires ruraux qui ont le sentiment de se
retrouver en première ligne malgré eux
donc toi regarde par exemple énergétique
donc rien d'érotique de fait et après
voilà des questions et quatre de chaque
ça va il est pas trop lent mais hanau sa
quinzaine de pages thème donc c'est
après pour qu'elles prennent des notes
basses tomber des tables est ce que faut
remettre des stylos à disposition réduit
c'est pas en collision
par contre alors là on n'est pas arrivé
emmanuel macron je pense qu'il a pas
conscience de travailler de ce que fait
un maire aujourd'hui de du quotidien de
la mer tiens on va pas s'amuser à
nouveau faire la synthèse bien vous
traduis en transcrivant
c'est un exercice facile
on a envoyé des liens pour aller trouver
des éléments mais derrière on est un peu
tout seul c'est vrai qu'on se sent un
peu oublié certes on n'a pas existé
pendant la première partie de mandat
sonné par le président de la république
et aujourd'hui il se rend compte que sur
le terrain la proximité c'est nous qui
l'avons d'état il a lancé ça et puis
débrouillez vous pour lui discuter de
sujets nationaux ne relève pas de ses
missions il a quand même accepté de
jouer le jeu
le débat a lieu dans la salle des fêtes
du village
la sénatrice laurence harribey et venues
y assister
moi ce qui m'a impressionné parce que
dans les petites communes on sait ce que
les gens votent on sait qu'elles font
leur idée c'est de voir des gens
complètement de n'importe quel parti
adhéré au mouvement des jeunes
non ça c'était la colère
c'est vrai on sentait des gens qu'ils
soient de droite de gauche de partout
adhéré au mouvement dire oui y'en a
marre écoutez nous le débat à titre
personnel je trouve très restrictif
puisqu'en fait il ya quatre thèmes et
pour moi ce débat doit être ouvert parce
que l'objectif c'est que des choses
ressortent et si on met des thèmes c'est
qu'on veut nous guider pour les accueils
par donc les quatre thèmes qui devaient
être abordées on les abordant la ce soir
je t'aime expression libre ou là on
pourra dire ce que l'on veut
une dizaine d'habitants a répondu
présent sur les 350 du village pour
certains c'est leur première réunion
publique hier alors démocratie et
citoyenneté
alors que le débat commence à peine la
première intervention donne le ton et
l'appareil villégier pas tout si c'est
un peu l'arbre qui cache la forêt
toujours les efforts comme nous
demandent de réfléchir à faire on
devrait plus ça doit être à tous les
niveaux si on va faire nos élus fo qui
montrent l'exemple
et malheureusement vu des exemples qui
compterait
pensez vous qu'il faut avant de tout
réduire les dépenses publiques
augmenter les impôts faire les deux même
temps où je ne sais pas juste la défense
tout chaud ça mais ont toujours sa mère
présent oui c'est sûr chez touché ce qui
guide les fins de mois difficiles
c'est le moteur de la colère alors la
question des impôts cristallise
l'attention tda
ça touche tout le monde que celui qu'axa
c'est un taureau de rsa il suffit qu'un
tout petit salaire plutôt la tva
après j'ai pas si c'est pour la tva je
crois que tu n'aimes pas qu'elle est
juste
réduire les dépenses de l'état les
dépenses sociales les dépendre des
qualités avec des collectivités
territoriales ou je ne sais pas on est
dépendants
oui ou non c'est pas moi je dis c'est
l'état qui nous coûte l'est pas oui moi
je vois sur le citoyen lambda dont je
fais partie comprend pas toujours
certains députés ou sénateurs donc
campagne de makonda parler de député de
sénateur après moi ça m'intéresserait
pouvoir changer de comprendre ce que
vous faites et les douars utilité
symboliquement s'il faut diminuer de 10%
pourquoi pas je veux dire maintenant
leader je préférerais qu'on diminue les
indemnités de 10% après je trouve qu'il
faut être cohérent c'est à dire que si
on veut des élus qui sont plus proches
du terrain c'est difficile
imaginez dans la fibre bon on supprime
ya six sénateurs moi il ya des moments
où je me dis oui pourquoi on en aurait 4
pourquoi pas d'accord parce que dalle
gironde
on est suffisamment nombreux et vous
prenez les hautes pyrénées il y en a que
deux
donc du coup eux si on applique la règle
ils ont nos rêves ne devrait pas en
avoir
donc il faudrait regrouper des
départements pour avoir un seul sénateur
et ça veut dire quoi un seul sénateur
ça veut dire vous n'avez qu'une seule
famille politique qui représentait et je
trouve que du point de vue de la
démocratie c'est pas tout à fait bon
alors pour mettre progrès accomplis
gagné je suis pas sûr pour gagner en
confiance mais en tout cas c'est un
début parce que je pense que c'est plus
les comportements que ce que s'il y
avait vraiment de confiance on se pose
on poserait pas cette keynes est cette
question trop de briser le bug trop tard
mais quand je parle de démocratie
participative
je ne met pas de côté complètement à la
représentativité ce que je me dis que de
toute façon mais même ceux qui sont en
politique maintenant les liens vers se
faire avec eux aussi causé mais avec la
population
de toute façon quatre thèmes avec une
trentaine de questions à chaque thème on
a pris l'exemple de celle du sénat
pourquoi parler du sénat et du comité
économique et social et pas parler de de
l'assemblée nationale ou ne pas parler
du mode de nomination d'un gouvernement
de l'élection présidentielle on regarde
aux élections législatives donc voilà on
sait on voit ce qu'il ya derrière
et moi je voudrais pas qu'il ya des
réponses simplistes qui soient données
simplement pour donner le gage
un ras-le-bol et que comme je le disais
tout à l'heure que le populisme d'état
répondre au populisme
populaire commence
[Musique]
derrière ce ras-le-bol se cache une
fracture territoriale dont les gilet
jaune sont le symptôme
en 10 ans le prix du logement à bordeaux
a augmenté de 40 % faisant fuir les
ménages en périphérie le fossé ne cesse
de se creuser entre la métropole et le
reste du territoire
ils se sentent a signé presque à
résidence ils sont dans le rural
ils n'ont pas les mêmes équipements bien
évidemment qu'il peut y avoir dans
l'urbain très souvent ils sont cons ils
n'ont pas de travail sont contraints de
venir sur la métropole pour travailler
donc ils subissent ce qui a nourri la
colère au début un les frais d'essence
j'entendais l'a1 qui disait dans une
réunion j'étais je mets 1h10 pour venir
travailler à bordeaux et on me montre ce
qu'ils vont à paris en 2 heures hélas
hélas bordeaux-paris la richesse on a
mis les moyens
on y met deux heures et ici sur nos
territoires 1h15 pour aller travailler
un salaire de 1400 euros
que voulez vous
sans eux ce grand débat n'aurait pas
existé c'est gilet jaune n'en attendent
pourtant rien décidant même de le
boycotter
[Musique]
d'entrée de jeu elle a dit non mais le
risque sans oublier la fiscalité on en
parle mais de toute façon ça changera
rien le grand débat je pense qu'on est
un peu de ces un peu de mon chemin je
c'est un grand débat pour un peu calmé
tout le monde est-ce que ça va arriver à
des choses concrètes derrière non je
pense pas s'il cesse semble pas prendre
cette direction
le problème c'est eux déjà donc c'est
pas à eux ils nous imposent les choses
depuis déjà trop d'années c'est par
rapport à toutes ces impôts tout ce
qu'on nous impose qu'on est descendu
dehors c'est pas pour aujourd'hui
rentrer en contact gentiment mais
également avec lui et en disant oui oui
on va répondre à vos questions c'est
plutôt lui qui peut répondre à nos
questions et lui a apporté les solutions
à nos problèmes
mobilisés depuis novembre dernier
ils ont quitté le rond-point de langon
pour se structurer et compte sur l'après
guerre en débat pour remobiliser
aux vues en plus de tout ce qui est dit
dans les médias sur les gilet jaune
qu'on est dégueu et tout le machin
justement c'est aussi une façon de
prouver au gouvernement qu'on
réfléchisse pour qu'ils y aient une
meilleure répartition des choses de
richesse des richesses et que c'est pas
forcément avoir un gros salaire
augmenter le smig et rien à côté non on
réfléchit sur plein d'autres choses
donc en fait des assemblées justement
pour leur dire le jour on sera prêts non
voilà nous maintenant aujourd'hui on a
ça et voilà comment on voit les choses
et là où seront obligés de nous entendre
parce qu'autrement ça ira
notre pouvoir et mais j'y crois
dur comme fer mais j'y crois dur comme
fer
ce gilet jaune de la première heure
n'avait pas prévu de rester en retrait
du grand débat mais voir le gouvernement
fermé la porte à certains sujets a été
pour ludovic le marrec un très mauvais
signal
le débat est clos d'avant c'est à dire
que on se on se coupe d'une d'un côté
complet d'une éventuelle discussion et
d'une éventuelle négociation est bon bah
du coup voilà aussi là pour le coup
c'est pas nous qui avons refusé le débat
cc c'est le le débat en lui même qui a
été tronquée finalement ça ressemble un
show télévisé ou pas d'ailleurs
et du coup on se dit que évidemment tout
ça s'est payé par parler par l'état donc
avec nos impôts et on se dit que ça ça
ressemble étrangement à une campagne
quand même politique
alors il a décidé de faire entendre sa
voix autrement loin du cadre officiel du
grand débat attention au cal les
spectateurs si vous oubliez vous allez
vous mettre derrière s'il vous plaît
vous installez vous c'est bon compte non
et quoi de mieux qu'une émission en
direct relayée sur les réseaux sociaux
pour faire remonter leurs revendications
et toucher ainsi le plus grand nombre et
moselle les yeux bonjour première
émission de la série que nous avons
présenté plusieurs étages l'iard mois
qui s'appelle sans langue de bois est
semblable sans tabou sans devons être
sûrs qu'il faut barda en france faire
une réforme globale de la fiscalité
cette réforme globale de la fiscalité va
devoir passer et là je vais vous défaire
de nouveau un amalgame elle va devoir
passer à des réductions de dépenses
publiques
est-ce que les gilet jaune je pense
veulent aussi vous dire c'est qu'il ya
un lien largement étroits entre le
matraquage fiscal et la perte du pouvoir
d'achat
nous nous souhaitons le rétablissement
purs et durs de l' isf est
particulièrement dense en ce qui
concerne la partie immobilière c'est à
dire les flux financiers
en ce qui concerne la fiscalité nos
propositions celles que l'on soutient
qu'on a fait remonter c'est évidemment
mais ça tout le monde l'a déjà dit la
suppression de la hausse de la csg et
particulièrement les prélèvements qui
sont sur les pensions de retraites sur
les pensions d'invalidité etc etc
c'est la première chose évidemment la
suppression et la non l'instauration des
fois qu'elle voulait qu'elle veuille
revenir de la taxe carbone d'accord
puisque le budget carburant en gironde
c'est par un vain mot voilà
on peut être maire conseiller
départemental président d'un syndicat
des eaux d'un syndicat quelconque autre
ménagère des eaux vice-président et
cetera et cetera donc encore le wifi de
donner une idée et ça constitue soutien
des gilet jaune
le maire était prêt à laisser une salle
à disposition de tous ceux qui voulaient
débattre
même s'il se dit quand même sceptique
sur la presse je crains quelques
déceptions par rapport aux demandes qui
sont faites mais c'est à dire que les
réponses n'ont pas être forcément en
accord avec les demandes et gilet jaune
et même des élus vis-à-vis des
communautés de communes vis-à-vis des
problématiques qui sont tenus pour des
raisons strictement politique jeu on a
l'impression que le président macro est
en campagne électorale
[Musique]
le boycott d'une majorité des gilet
jaune c'est bordelaise ne le comprennent
pas ses deux voisines voit le grand
débat comme une opportunité et ont
décidé d'organiser une réunion publique
en centre ville une première pour elle
ça va durer vous prie de faire ensuite
le deuxième thème l'assemblée de la
choisir comme nom moi je trouve que le
plus important qui arrive qui résume un
peu l'ensemble ces dérèglements
climatiques
on commence on est dans le bon sens mais
il n'ya pas que les initiatives peuvent
parler de coût et les gens je pense que
ces besoins il avait besoin d'avoir
aussi la parole voilà parce que on se
sent sont mis à part on se sort décalé
et on comprend pas on comprend pas et
nous aussi on avait une tonnelle notre
vie notre sénatrice une réunion à
l'initiative de citoyens à laquelle
françoise cartron a accepté de
participer ce sera la seule élus
présents de ce soir la piste
on pourrait peut-être se poser pourquoi
les chambres pourront pas voter
moi je pense que c'est une méfiance ils
ont plus du tout confiance dans leurs
politiques et les balades depuis une
quarantaine d'années et pour moi les
chez les jaunes ça représente à langer
attention je pèse mes mots je suis pas
je suis pas agressif je suis pas un
casseur de machin enfin deux camions je
vais pas taguer je vais rien faire
mais pourquoi un c'est un soulèvement du
peuple alors quand je dis sur les
tenants du peuple c'est pas le mot avec
le grand s soulever et puis faire partir
une politique mais c'est un
mécontentement de toute la politique qui
a été mis en place depuis une
quarantaine d'années c'est cette
question qui font se posait déjà causé
l'accusé mais pourquoi ils ont plus
confiance parce que les gens et que les
gens sont élus avec avec moins 50% des
suffrages
si si là c'est grave ôter toute façon
ah oui mais n'a fait qu'elle est la
solution moi je pensais le premier tour
oui il n'y a pas d' excuses pour dire je
suis pas allé voter parce que finalement
j'ai pas trouvé j'ai pas confiance non
c'est par une journée dans le plat au
premier tour il ya quand même plus 50
pour nord vient pas non non non il ya
même plus de vote parfois deuxième tour
qu'au premier tour au deuxième tour fois
oui d'accord dans le choix donc c'est
contradictoire quand vous avez une
palette large de 12 candidats jouent pas
ils vont pas et après ils vivent pour
faire émerger un candidat
voilà donc bien sûr qu'ils sont pas
contents donc mais où l'on n'y a pas de
raison non non mais là vous fier à paris
on a collé droit et on a pu le voir
donc on est à la limite on est plus
citoyen ce qui compte c'est qu'on
consomme
je vote pour macron six mois après ils
m'emmerde
eh ben je veux qu'on en change et on
fait un référendum alors commencé comme
dans le mariage alors contre
l'abstention l'idée du vote obligatoire
refait surface
c'est ce que madame disait en place et
les choses c'est vrai que c'est pas
toujours tous et pas toujours bon de
quelle solution suppose pas se donne
tout ce qu'elle peut amener un maximum
de personnes à s'exprimer alors
qu'actuellement elle sait que ce n'est
même pas me paraît très positif et alors
comment ben je n'ai pas droit
oui une loi ni comment il faut c'est
bien elle sanctionne
yann pas si ces gens-là s'exprimer dans
un pote
ils réclament et des signes botte de 100
% de la population sera autre chose le
comme valeur que s'il ya une bonne à
vote de 45 % de population ou bien
trouver un jour une solution contre 20
si on n'a pas de contrainte
je vois pas de solution sinon on va se
retrouver avec les avec les mêmes
problèmes de gens qui disent ah bah oui
y'a qu'à faut qu'on il faut pas faire
ceci voilà on veut faire un référendum
bon d'initiative citoyenne c'est ça
représente quoi ça veut dire qu'il ya
iliad mettons cent mille personnes ou
deux cent mille personnes en étant très
optimiste qui vont s'exprimer
c'est pas pareil que s'il ya 100 % des
gens qui sont en âge de voter qui votent
sommes keller même deux heures nous
sommes arrivés 18 heures et bien je vous
remercie de votre ténacité pour mettre
ces trous d'utiliser mais qui ont fusé
[Musique]
je ne crois pas qu'on pourra refaire de
la politique comme on en faisait avant
le processus du grand débat national
les citoyens ont pris la parole ils ont
dit l'homme
je crois qu'il ya une énergie
démocratique et citoyenne qui s'est
libérée cette énergie citoyenne et
démocratique on la fera pas rentrer dans
sa baguette magique ça certainement pas
un processus libéré il faudra lui
trouver les acteurs institutionnels
il faudra que le monde de la
représentation politique d'une certaine
manière face sa place à cette prise de
parole citoyenne
[Musique]
ce